foreign
Ann Arbor Michigan hi Joe welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey how are you better than I deserve
what's up
um so my girlfriend and I we own a
duplex uh we bought in 2020 and around
October
um and we were thinking about moving uh
somewhere else apparently we live in the
bottom half and we were renting the top
unit
um up until recently our our last headed
just moved out
um we kind of don't
I don't want to say what over the
landlord life but
um
we're not sure if we want to use the
space
um for you know we both work from home
so we're considering using it as like a
home office
um or renting it out or just moving
entirely and
either renting out both units and taking
that income towards whether whatever we
decide to either rent or buy
um
or
um selling it completely and just moving
away from it and buying something
um new so ding ding ding ding ding
that's the one you're gonna do because
you already decided that for you called
me you're done homie
what's that sell it yeah yeah you're out
you're done you everything in your
language your voice tone everything said
you were done
you're ready to move and have a fresh
new clean thing and you don't want
Runners anymore it's all over you often
often people call and we're trying to
talk them out of their hysteria because
what they're proposing with the real
estate deal is insane you're the exact
opposite you've already you've already
said you want someone to tell you you're
not insane you're not insane I would
sell the crap out of this thing
and I mean in three years I think we
paid 164 we've done some Renovations
we've improved the kitchen and the
backyard and everything so I think we
could maybe make some money off of it
probably sell it for 200 something yeah
good
um but also the area that we're living
in is kind of developing they're doing a
lot of you know you know the roads Joe
yeah you're over it
ha
don't talk yourself back into it you're
not going to talk me into it you're over
it yeah this is how ulcers are formed
when reality is in front of you and
you're like yeah but one time they're
gonna Edge and they're gonna put a curb
in you know let me tell you man I I got
a in a real estate business I was 18
years old and this old man had this uh
piece of property that was about five
miles from the commercial area it was a
piece of formal piece of farmland and um
he wanted like a million dollars for it
it was worth a hundred thousand and he
said but but it's someday it's going to
be commercial
it's been 40 years
still not it just now turned commercial
he died a decade ago but it just now
turned commercial I mean you know so you
can you can what if if ands and buts and
all that the rest of your life on real
estate it always moves at a different
speed than we think it's going to faster
or slower doesn't matter none of that
matters you're done with this situation
it aren't you right aren't you well
emotionally you're done with it
well the one thing is just living
underneath the tenant is what I'm done
but you don't have to apologize it's
okay we move and we rent both if you
listen to the show I tell people not to
buy duplexes with a tenant next door but
if you're going to you must understand
the good news is your tinnitus next door
you can find them the bad news is your
tenant is next door they can find you
right and that's what you discovered
right
well the the one situation I wanted to
ask is if we move out we rent the bottom
and the top and we're no longer there
and we're using that income towards you
know a rental or something is that not
worth it it's not worth the headache
sure rental property is fine but Joe
doesn't like renters
yeah it's a it's a lot I mean yeah oh
I'm not talking about everybody else and
I'm not talking about the concept of
investment real estate I'm talking about
you
you're done yeah you don't want this
anymore
someday later you may want to be a
landlord again but right now
um you've had your you've had your trip
on the crazy train and you're tired of
the Crazy Train
that's true yeah yeah that's okay take a
break from crazy go get you a house and
by the way don't buy a house for
somebody you're not married to again
okay well you're gonna get bit you're
gonna get bit if you listen if you're
gonna buy a house with her put a ring on
it buddy because you're gonna get
yourself in a mess legally
because you can't break up with a house
you can break up with a girl
but the house both of you own together
and you don't have the benefit of
divorce court for the judge to tell you
what to do because you are not in a
marriage you are in a partnership
without any partnership documents
and so if she just decides to run off
tomorrow to wherever Timbuktu and you
can't find her oh well you own a house
and you can't sell it because you be
stuck I know she's not gonna go crazy
but those tenants were going to be easy
to work with that was passive income and
so things don't always turn out exactly
like we think they're going to please
for God's sakes don't buy another house
with somebody you're not married to
people stop doing that you get we see
people in our dad gum counseling offices
every week financial
disasters getting foreclosed on they
should be able to sell the house there's
plenty of equity but we can't find said
X
who spun out and took off and wasn't
married to and we would not have jobs if
it wouldn't if it didn't happen to you
yep it can always happen to you that's
what makes us so relevant